hey everybody Welcome to the David
packman show I'm producer Pat Ford
filling in for David today David is on
vacation for much of this week he will
be back on Friday a number of
Republicans are calling for the arrest
of Joe Biden and also Hunter Biden and
any other Democrats that they can
possibly Trump up charges against as a
way to retaliate against Donald Trump
getting indicted and then arrested last
week in New York now what issues do they
want to arrest Biden and these other
Democrats over that's not as important
they just want to do this because they
see it as a way to get Vindication right
because Donald Trump for once in his
entire life is finally being held
accountable to some degree to some small
degree after his years and years of
criminality I spoke about this matter on
last week's Friday bonus show the
award-winning world famous bonus show I
might add but there have since been more
Republicans adding to this chorus of
right-wing calls to do something like
this to to Levy charges against Joe
Biden and these other Democrats first
and foremost we're hearing from
Congressman James Comer who chairs the
house oversight committee he went on Fox
and Friends late last week to comment on
how there are these district attorneys
in places like Kentucky and Tennessee
who are trying to come up with some way
to charge the bidens even though they
don't know what issue they're going to
do it over let's take a look at this
clip and I had two two calls yesterday
one from a county attorney in Kentucky
and one from a county attorney in
Tennessee they were they were Republican
obviously that both states are heavily
Republican they want to know if there
are ways they can go after the bidens
now and they've opened up a can of worms
they've set precedents now that we can't
go back on and now we're going to see a
Judicial System that's already bogged
down with with doing what they're
supposed to do and that's going after
real criminals uh people that are
committing real crime now what
jurisdiction would these DA's have to
indict Biden there of course isn't any
because the crime would have had to take
place in one of those two states
remember Donald Trump's hush money
payment that took place in New York City
and where are the charges coming from
about this you guessed it New York City
the issues that Republicans talk about
potentially indicting Biden on have to
do with his supposed corruption even
though they really can't articulate it
all that well but they'll mention
Ukraine or China or some other foreign
country some sometimes they'll talk
about the classified documents Scandal
that implicated Joe Biden even though
Donald Trump is way more guilty on that
topic so if you're going to go after
Biden on this it stands the reason you'd
also have to go after Donald Trump if
you do go after Biden on any of these
topics it would probably need to come
from the federal governments or at least
involve the states in question like the
supposed crime that took place would
have had to have taken place in one of
these states but the fact is that this
has nothing to do with you know trying
to stay consistent or trying to uphold
the rule of law or trying to you know
make sure that this is done in a proper
way it really is just about getting
Vindication we're also now hearing from
whiny hysterical right-wing talk show
host Mark Levin about this topic he's
also trying to get someone anyone to
charge Joe Biden and the Democrats for
what again not important but he just
knows that it has to be done here's Mark
Levin and once again
for multiple times
that shows her all over the country it's
heard all over the world actually
I'm asking Republican prosecutors out
there to take a very good look at your
own statutes
local state and even Federal but
particularly the state prosecutors the
DA's the state prosecutors and so forth
see if there's anything there that you
can use to charge Biden
or any senior Democrat official
I mean if you're not 100 certain you're
80 percent certain that it'll fly then
do it
it's the only way this will stop
because otherwise this will continue
you'd be doing it for your country
you'd be doing it in the name of the law
it is a legitimate reply and response
it's the only way to at least begin the
process of clawing us
back from the abyss because we're
already falling into the abyss in
addition to the of the DA's in Tennessee
and Kentucky that Comer mentioned and
Mark Levin talking about how we got to
charge Biden we're also hearing from Tom
fitton who is the president of the
conservative Legal Group Judicial Watch
he said quote all bets are off you can
expect grand jury indictments of leftist
politicians like Biden former house
Speaker Nancy Pelosi and Senate Majority
Leader Chuck Schumer as surely as night
follows day Mike Davis a former Chief
counsel for nominations on the Senate
Judiciary Committee and president of the
article three projects said that quote
if New York can turn a routine
settlement of a business dispute seven
years ago into a felony I think our
Republican AGS and DA's should get
creative get creative is what he says
like he seems to admit there that
there's no actual reason to charge the
bidens it wouldn't be right to do so but
he wants them to get creative he went
out to say that two wrongs don't make a
right but it does make it even and
that's what this is about getting even
so he's out and out saying yeah we're
just gonna make it up we're just going
to come up with whatever reason we can
charge the bidens on hearing from these
Republicans you would think that Donald
Trump just didn't get a pass like he did
over and over again throughout the
entire course of his political career he
did get a pass and now he's finally to
the smallest degree being held
accountable for just one of these
alleged crimes this is the hush money
payment of course the incident that took
back a place back in 2016 his then fixer
Michael Cohen who's since been a guest
on this program
um went to prison over this Donald Trump
was a sitting president at the time and
he was protected by this idea that
there's this long-standing precedent
that you can't charge a sitting
president it hasn't actually been tested
before but that's long been the
tradition here in this country but that
wasn't the only issue that you could
have possibly gone after Trump on of
course there was the Russia Scandal
where Robert Mueller concluded his
report that Donald Trump should be
charged for obstruction of justice but
since it was believed you couldn't
indict a sitting president he was saying
that it's actually congress's
responsibility to hold him accountable
accountable Congress should impeach
Donald Trump and of course they ended up
not doing that then there was a scandal
a new train which would have been
criminal if done by anyone else who was
not a sitting president
um you know withholding congressionally
approved aid from a country saying that
he's not going to give that to him
unless they dig up dirt on his political
opponent then there's of course the
fraudulent business practices that the
Trump organization committed where he
would inflate the value of his assets
when it was time to take out a loan and
he would deflate them when it was time
to pay taxes they chose not to go after
Trump personally on this matter just to
hold the company accountable there's
obviously the phone call in Georgia
where he pressured Brad braffensberger
to find him 11 280 votes that didn't
exist when it was clear that he had lost
the election hopefully there will be
some accountability on that hopefully we
eventually get some charges out of
Georgia but thus far it hasn't happened
there's the January 6th Insurrection
where he sent his supports to the
Capitol to commit a coup and then he
didn't try to stop them once the coup
was actually unfolding there's a
classified document Scandal which I
alluded to before where he took
sensitive information to Mar-A-Lago and
then lied about giving the documents
back when he actually didn't got to the
point where the FBI had to actually
conduct a search on his home and seize
the documents to get them back to the
National Archives so all of these things
and more all of these things are
indictable in fractions he's only so far
being held accountable for one of them
just one of them and it's probably the
least serious of all of them and for
whatever reason Republicans feel as
though this is grounds to go after
Democrats on and you know make this a
tit for tats sort of thing so Trump has
gotten away with so much what would it
take for Republicans to accept that he
was actually worthy of prosecution
without turning this into a political
game like would he actually have to
shoot someone on Fifth Avenue even if
that happened even if he did shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue I think they
would still bring the conversation back
to Hunter Biden and the laptop from hell
but that's the latest Republicans trying
to muck up charges against Joe Biden and
the other Democrats that they want to
make their new political targets I hope
that the American public sees through
this I hope that if Biden actually is
indicted for some reason then or the the
American public will be able to
understand that it's Republicans just
trying to play dirty political games and
Biden isn't actually worthy of being
charged for anything but that's what
Republicans are doing right now once
Donald Trump got indicted and then
arrested as a result of the New York
hush money payment investigation the
consensus among political wonks became
that his approval numbers at least among
Republicans would actually go up and
this is of course because Republicans
love claiming to be the victim and they
love to pacify Donald Trump when he
plays the victim when he goes around the
country and acts like oh everyone's just
trying to get me and every investigation
into me isn't actually because I
committed any wrongdoing it's all just
part of a democratic hit piece it's a
Witch Hunt and it's all very unfair
despite of course Republicans claiming
to be the people who support rule of law
law and order personal responsibility
not acting like a fragile special
snowflake all these other things they do
make an exception to these rules when it
comes to their dear leader Donald Trump
so the prediction was that the
indictment slash arrest news was
actually going to help Donald Trump in
the upcoming primary battle and it seems
like that's actually playing out because
we now have a new poll from Reuters
ipsos which shows that Donald Trump is
at 58 support in the Republican primary
with Ron DeSantis all the way down at 21
that's 37 down which is quite astounding
now we know that DeSantis tends to do
better in these pole uh matchups when
he's in a one-on-one competition against
Donald Trump since his support doesn't
get diluted amongst these other
candidates who don't really have a
chance realistically but at least as it
pertains to this poll it doesn't seem to
have that much of an effect because in
this poll we see Donald Trump at 58 we
see DeSantis at 21 and then all the way
down at the bottom of the list we see
Mike Pence at four percent he probably
shouldn't even just bother to run at
this point I don't see what reason he
would want to get in this race for Nikki
Haley is at a pathetic one percent even
though she is officially running we have
Liz Cheney who's at three percent she
may run but my guess is that if she does
decide to run it would be as an
independent to sabotage a potential
Trump candidacy rather than to run as a
republican where she'd have no shot at
the at the primary uh we have Mike
Pompeo Vivek ramaswamy and Glenn yunkin
who all have one percent support and
then Christy gnome Chris Christie Tim
Scott and Krista Nunu all are at zero
percent now this poll is particularly
good for Trump his 58 percent is up from
the same poll that had him at 48 percent
earlier this month and 44 percent from
the middle of March we of course can
never glean too much from one poll and
we tend to see regression back to the
mean but it is important to remember
that more charges May soon be coming
against Donald Trump particularly out of
Georgia and maybe even from Washington
DC if that's the case Donald Trump may
be able to build up on his momentum and
this race could be over before it even
starts the first primaries aren't until
February of next year so that's like 10
months away from now and there's plenty
of time remaining but with the santis
currently so far behind he may get
scared out of announcing altogether he
may assess that it's just better for him
to wait until 2028 or 2032 if he wants a
real shot at winning this thing because
at that point Donald Trump is not going
to be in the picture anymore and as long
as he can continue to stay relevant in
the world of politics keep doing what
he's doing in Florida uh maybe he'll be
able to still be relevant and run a
successful campaign in a future election
cycle uh of course the Santas seem to
have a real shot at winning this thing
following the 2022 primaries when he way
outperformed the trumpian candidates but
I believe that his star may have peaked
too early and now it's Donald Trump's
turn once again we also don't suspect
that DeSantis would do what it takes to
take down Trump which is to go at him
forcefully and directly he'd likely be
tepid for as long as possible until he
has absolutely no choice but to go after
Donald Trump in desperation once it's
already too late that's what we saw took
place in um 2016 in the Republican
primary I remember Marco Rubio and Ted
Cruz at the very last minute tried to
get into the dirt with Donald Trump but
it was far too late at that point they
should have tried to do it earlier if
they were going to take down the king in
Republican circles and if DeSantis
decides not to run if he announces he's
not going to enter the race we can just
wrap this thing up right Donald Trump is
going to have the nomination easily in
2024 spare me if you think that Nikki
Haley or Mike Pompeo or ASA Hutchinson
is going to be able to put a stop to
that and of course Republicans are only
shooting themselves in the foot by doing
this by choosing Trump since Trump does
not match up very well against Biden or
any other Democrat in the general
election DeSantis does a lot better than
Trump does against a democrat in the
general election and Trump is going to
have this stench of criminality now on
him that he didn't necessarily have in
Prior election Cycles plus there's these
other things that he has to worry about
like the capital Insurrection this will
be the first time that Trump is on the
ballot since uh January 6 2021
so that's probably not going to play
well amongst general election voters so
there's this real Stockholm syndrome
going on within the Republican party
where even if other Republican figures
and right-wing voters know that he's bad
for the party he lost them elections in
2018 and 2020 and 2022
and he's probably poised to do it again
in 2024 even though they know all that
stuff everyone's still too afraid to
cross him and I guess they just love his
personality so much that they'll be
willing to support him even when the
evidence shows that he is a loser and
he's only hurting the party so that's
the latest on the polling Trump seems to
be running away with this thing at the
moment
um and we'll see if Ron DeSantis even
decides to get into this race because
it's not looking so good for him at the
moment all right we're going to go to a
break right now we'll be back with much
more of the David Pacman show right
after this one of our sponsors today is
Bon charge I have always enjoyed dry
saunas you get in there your heart rate
is up dilates the blood vessels can
soothe achy joints and muscles it's
relaxing it's just a great way to remove
a little stress Bon charge is the
creator of the infrared sauna blanket
which you can enjoy from home super easy
to set up heats up fast you don't have
to have your head and side like at a
traditional sauna at the gym nice for
meditating or reading getting work done
relaxing I have found it to be a great
way to unwind at the end of a long day
easy to clean Sleek lightweight design
easy to store and comes with a 12 month
warranty and of course if you don't love
it returns are super easy but I think
you will love it go to boncharge.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman 15 for 15
off the link is down below
welcome back to the David Pacman show
I'm producer Pat Ford filling in for
David today he is on vacation and we'll
be back at the end of the week in
response to the mass shooting that took
place in Tennessee a couple of weeks
back Republicans who are in control of
the state legislature have decided to
take action but not in any sort of
substantive way not by strengthening
background checks or Banning certain
types of weapons instead they've decided
to expel to members of the legislative
body who took part in the protest and
essentially broke the rules of decorum
in the legislative body in so doing
Tennessee lawmakers expelled two members
from the state legislature Justin Jones
and Justin Pearson after they in a third
member Gloria Johnson took part in a
protest against gun violence from the
floor of the chamber the vote took place
last Thursday with Johnson surviving
expulsion by only a single vote notably
Jones and Pearson are black whereas
Johnson the one who survived the
expulsion vote is white I'll leave it up
to you to decide whether that has
anything to do with the results
following the mass shooting there was a
protest at the legislative chamber to
try to get lawmakers to do anything at
all about this issue of gun violence and
using their position as representatives
to be actually inside the house chamber
these three lawmakers used a bullhorn
and temporarily disrupted the official
business of the legislative body leading
the Republican super majority to call
for a recess let's take a look at some
of the video of the protests taking
place
[Music]
and
foreign
Republicans who hold a large majority of
seats immediately pledged a rapid
response they stripped Johnson and Jones
of committee assignments I don't believe
Pearson yet had any committee
assignments motions to expel the three
from the legislature were introduced by
three different members of the state
legislature on April 3rd accusing the
trio of disorderly Behavior now to put
this in context it's very rare for
expulsions to take place in the
Tennessee legislature just eight
lawmakers have been expelled from the
house in the state's history six of
those were Confederates who were
expelled in the 19th century for
refusing to affirm the citizenship of
formerly enslaved black people in the
20th century a legislator was expelled
after being convicted of bribery and
most recently in 2016 a member was
expelled for sexual misconduct so this
expulsion wasn't really about the merits
it only happened because Republicans had
the votes to be able to do it and they
took advantage of that and in fact
Justin Jones one of the two ousted
members highlighted in a speech that he
gave on the floor some of the things
that his fellow members of the
legislature did over the years or at
least were accused of doing that did
ultimately not result in an expulsion
let's take a look at him talking about
that let's talk about expulsion
for years one of your colleagues who was
an admitted child molester sat in this
chamber
no expulsion
one member sits in this chamber who was
found guilty of domestic violence no
expulsion
we had a former speaker sit in this
chamber who is now under federal
investigation no expulsion we have a
member still under federal investigation
no expulsion
we had a member p in another member's
chair in this chamber
no expulsion
in fact they're in leadership now the
hope is that from a political standpoint
this will backfire on Republicans
because not only has this brought the
issue of gun violence more to the
Forefront and how members of Congress at
the state and federal level aren't
really doing anything about it it's also
made these three National figures the
Tennessee three as they're now being
called vice president Kamala Harris
visited the lawmakers in Nashville on
Friday and President Biden also spoke
with the three via conference call
inviting them to visit the white house
now to be clear I don't know if
disrupting proceedings and using a
bullhorn is the right way to go about
protesting this sort of matter despite
it being peaceful of course and despite
it being clearly intended to only being
to be a temporary disruption and that's
because if let's say the shoe was on the
other foot let's say you know at the
Capitol we saw Marjorie Taylor green and
Lauren bober do this exact same thing on
one of the issues that they care about
would we be totally fine with it I'm not
sure sure and I just want to stay
consistent on this right nevertheless I
think that expulsion would be way too
extreme if that was to take place I
think the most appropriate thing to do
in that sort of instance would be maybe
a censure right because these people
were duly elected to represent their
constituents and barring some sort of
extreme event they should be able to
serve out their terms so I think
censoring them which is basically just
an official condemnation would have made
a lot more sense for something like this
breaking the rules of decorum but
Republicans in this situation they were
just trying to abuse their power and be
vindictive on this matter and then final
point I want to make on this some on the
right are comparing this to January 6th
when there's absolutely no comparison to
be drawn here uh to the capital
Insurrection on that day January 6 2021
we saw rioters beating up cops we saw
the Senate chamber get overtaken we saw
several people die based on you know
because of what happened it was directed
and then not put a stop to by the then
president of the United States and the
intent of the protest that became a riot
was to overthrow the government to end
democracy in the United States this on
the other hand was a peaceful protest
that was yeah it's sure at times a
little rowdy
but there was no intention of
overthrowing the government there was no
clear acts of violence and it was not
intended to end democracy in the state
of Tennessee so spare me those
comparisons it will be interesting to
see what happens next and Pearson and
Jones the two who are expelled from the
legislature will be able to run for
their seats again let's hope that
they're able to win back their seats and
then all will be good congresswoman
Alexandria ocasio-cortez is calling for
the impeachment of Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas over his failure to
disclose luxury trips paid for by a
republican Mega donor we told you last
week how propublica broke this story
that Thomas has been in the pocket of
right-wing billionaire Harlan Crowe for
decades Thomas has vacationed on Crow's
162 Foot super yacht and flown on his
Bombardier Global 5000 jet which would
have cost half a million dollars if the
money had come from Thomas and he had
charted it himself the trips put Thomas
in contact with corporate Executives and
political activists violating Federal
disclosure laws and long-standing norms
for a judge's conduct this is a
violation of his ethical obligations as
a Justice and he disregarded Federal
disclosure laws we were wondering if
Thomas was going to ever say anything at
all about this because he so rarely
comments on anything before the public
but I suppose this Scandal was bad
enough that he at least felt the need to
say something about it he said quote
Harlan and Kathy Crowe are among our
dearest friends and we have been friends
for over 25 years as friends do we have
joined them on a number of family trips
during the more than quarter Century we
have known them early in my tenure at
the court I sought guidance from my
colleagues and others in the Judiciary
and was advised that this sort of
personal Hospitality from close personal
friends who did not have business before
the court was not reportable
I have endeavored to follow that Council
throughout my tenure and have always
sought to comply with the disclosure
guidelines these guidelines are now
being changed as the committee of the
judicial conference responsible
Financial disclosure for the entire
Federal Judiciary just this past month
announced new guidance and it is of
course my intent to follow this guidance
in the future now if you're as jaded and
skeptical when it comes to Politics As I
Am you may think that this is where the
story ends because Thomas is basically
never held accountable for anything
including the Anita Hill allegations
including the conflicts of interest that
he had with his wife Jenny Thomas being
a far-right activist and a complete
Kool-Aid Drinker when it comes to the
conspiracy theories about voter fraud in
the 2020 election it seems like at this
point it's only representative
Alexandria ocasio-cortez who wants to do
anything substantial to hold Thomas
accountable for these ethical violations
she tweeted her support for impeaching
Thomas late last week and here she is
yesterday on CNN's State of the Union
with Dana Bash laying out why she
believes that Thomas needs to be removed
from his post over this I believe that
the and it is The house's responsibility
to pursue that investigation in the form
of impeachment well let me ask you I
mean you you know full well that the
house is now run by Republicans
how are you going to move what you're
calling for articles of impeachment
through a house that is run by
Republicans
you know I think it's a it's a perf
there is the question of the politics of
what we are doing and there's the
question of the the course and the
accountability and the structures of
what we are doing I admit it is a it is
very difficult to see a path in a
Republican party that refuses to hold
itself accountable and in fact breaches
the law itself now of course we run into
the reality that Republicans control the
House of Representatives and there's
basically no world in which Kevin
McCarthy decides to introduce articles
of impeachment against Clarence Thomas
at least not over this issue but I do
believe it's good that there are calls
for him to face an Ethics violation
calls for him to step down and this call
for him to be impeached I do Wonder
however if AOC is the right person to do
this since she's such a polarizing
figure and so many people are just going
to write this off as a radical leftist
trying to attack a well-established
Supreme Court Justice over an issue that
may maybe not impeachable in their eyes
but even though she seems to recognize
that she's still deciding to be the one
voice of reason in this matter the one
person calling for impeachment and
saying you know if no one else is going
to do it no one else is going to bring
articles impeachment forward I'm going
to be the one to do so honestly this is
probably the best that we can hope for
right because Republicans rarely ever
hold their own accountable you know
they're sticking by Donald Trump despite
his criminality despite the January 6th
Insurrection they're sticking by George
Santos despite him getting elected on
the basis of countless countless lies
and they're also going to let Clarence
Thomas presumably get away with this
because they don't actually care about
integrity or rule of law or any of these
other things that they claim to care
about any of these other supposed
principles that they claim to espouse
I'm Pat Ford filling in for David Pacman
today we'll be back with much more of
the David Pacman show right after this
commercial break
welcome back to the David Pacman show
I'm producer Pat Ford filling in for
David today tomorrow Luke Beasley is
going to be hosting the program and then
fairing cousins will be filling in
Wednesday Thursday before David makes
his triumphant return to the show on
Friday let's talk about the economy the
issue that has plagued President Biden
throughout much of his presidency
especially during the year 2022 was the
high inflation rate peaking at 9.1
percent in the summer and of course the
reasons for the high inflation are
numerous there was the supply chain
issues the Russian war in Ukraine and
the economic stimulus programs that came
in response to the covid-19 pandemic and
for the past year the Federal Reserve
has been steadily hiking interest rates
to cool that inflation number down it
does indeed appear to be working as
inflation has been at a steady downtrend
for eight or nine months now with it
currently sitting at around six percent
however there's still a ways to go
before we get to that two to three
percent rate that the FED wants to see
we've talked in the past about how you
want a little bit of inflation so that
people are incentivized to spend money
now rather than wait to purchase things
in the future because if people
anticipate that things are going to be
more expensive in the future they're
going to want to pay for them now but of
course if the inflation rate is too high
then people's savings get depleted and
things get way too expensive as we've
seen to some degree over the last year
or two well
what will necessarily happen as a result
of trying to Tamp down on inflation in
the higher interest rates that come with
it is the slowing of job growth since
businesses will have less money to hire
new people and as borrowing money
becomes more expensive and that is
finally what we're seeing it took a long
time to get there but the latest job
numbers from the month of March 2023
show that we are finally getting to a
cooling down of the number of people
getting hired it's still an increase of
course month to month as the population
increases but the rate is slowing down
now job creation slowed to 236 000 for
the month almost reaching the level that
President Biden said would stabilize the
economy and prices more Americans joined
the labor force and wage gains fell
slightly which could help to further
cool inflation
the lower wage gains is yet another
necessary evil to calming down the rate
of inflation it's one of these
unfortunate Necessities that is seen by
an economist says you know what you have
to do to bring about a lower inflation
rate the unemployment rate currently
sits at 3.5 percent which is lower than
what we saw under Trump lower than what
we saw under President Obama lower than
what we saw under President Bush and
given how Trump would endlessly brag
about uh the economy he would love to
have seen these numbers during his
tenure Biden should be doing the exact
same thing because 3.5 percent is
essentially what we would call Full
Employment but it is cautioning however
that there is more work to do when it
comes to the economy to bring down high
prices that are squeezing workers and
families Biden previously stated that
monthly job creation needed to fall to
around 150 000 of 150 000 150 000 jobs
so there still is a ways to go
I understand that this is maybe not the
most exciting story but this come down
uh from the high inflation rate we
always thought would take some time and
indeed it has taken some time it's been
eight or nine months at this point since
inflation has peaked and it was always
going to come with some sacrifices when
it comes to other economic indicators
like jobs number slowing down like wage
growth slowing down and as these months
go on and job creation cools and as the
inflation rate cools we're definitely
hearing less and less from Republicans
about the economy overall uh perhaps
that's why they're so focused on these
culture War issues these days talking
about trans people and drag shows and
other topics like that because they just
can't seem to be making they can't seem
to make Salient points when it comes to
gas prices anymore they can't really
talk about the stock market as that has
recovered to some degree can't really
talk about inflation since that's long
since peaked and you know over the last
year they've just been talking about
nonsense because they really can't focus
on these kitchen tables affect issues
effectively like they were able to about
a year ago and it's of course impossible
to predict where the economy is going to
go next right we don't know if things
are going to have a turnaround and we'll
reverse course and go in the opposite
direction of where we want to see things
terribly uh difficult to Def uh to
predict the economy short to mid term
but looking at the data looking at the
trajectories of these different things
my sense is that by the time the 2024
election rolls around we could
definitely have inflation under control
with job numbers maybe not quite as good
as they are now but still at a very
healthy level the Federal Reserve will
then have the green light to start
lowering interest rates again and things
could end up being in solid shape when
it's time for voters to go to the polls
in 2024 and not only is that good for us
stakeholders who participate in the
American economy it could also be good
for President Biden's re-election
chances if he indeed decides to run and
it could make Republicans basically
unable to speak effectively about these
kitchen table issues and they'll have to
resort to talking about the culture War
whatever their new pet issue is for the
day so inflation cooling down jobs
numbers cooling down along with it and
of course we'll continue to follow it
federal judges in two states have issued
contradictory decisions that could
significantly impact access to a drug
that is used in nearly all medication
abortions here in the United States U.S
District Judge Matthew kasmarek in Texas
ruled that the Food and Drug
Administration the FDA improperly
approves the abortion pill muffapristone
over 20 years ago and he issued a
nationwide injunction pausing the fda's
approval of the drug which is set to
take effect in seven days from the time
of the ruling this marks the first time
in history that a court has claims the
authority to single-handedly pull a drug
from the market it's legally dubious
that a judge has this sort of
wide-ranging power within hours of that
decision U.S District Judge Thomas O
Rice issued a ruling in a separate case
in Washington state that blocked the FDA
from quote altering the status quo and
rights as it relates to the availability
of muffapristone the problem of course
is that the FDA cannot conceivably
comply with both of these contradictory
orders at once and because cosmarik's
order is broader covering all 50 states
it guarantees that muffler prystone will
be suspended in much of the country at
least temporarily
only the Supreme Court can resolve this
looming crisis it has very little time
to do so the window is closing and
knowing how right-wing this Supreme
Court is particularly on the abortion
issue this could spell disaster uh
President Biden said about this quote if
this ruling were to stands then there
will be virtually no prescription
approved by the FDA that would be safe
from these kinds of political
ideological attacks it is the next step
towards the national ban on abortion the
Republican elected officials have vowed
to make law in America the justice
department appealed to the U.S court of
appeals for the fifth district which has
a reputation for being conservative
unfortunately mafa Prestone was approved
by the FDA back in 2000 for use in a
combination with a second drug called
misoprostol more than half of all
abortions in the United States are done
using a medication and the two drug
combination has been used in ninety
percent of them since 2020. so as as
David likes to say this is shocking but
not surprising we knew that when the
conservative Supreme Court overturned
Roe versus Wade last year that
Republicans were not going to be content
with just that alone because you know
the overturning of Roe versus Wade still
allows for abortion to take place in the
United States it basically just kicks
the issue back to the States but to be
clear the use of muffiprystone could not
be compared to the medical procedure
known as abortion at all I mean these
are two different things I think both
should be legal but the circumstances
surrounding both of these issues are
very different the main difference of
course is the timing right because a
regular abortion procedure will
typically be performed after
a couple of months of pregnancy you know
maybe six to 12 weeks into the pregnancy
whereas an abortion pill can be taken up
to about 11 weeks after the first day of
the last menstrual period uh the
procedure of course is very different
with one requiring a medical
professional to surgically remove the
fetus from the uterus while the other is
as simple as taking a pill I understand
that you know there's an ethical
conundrum when you're talking about
ending the pregnancy uh when the fetus
is at the end of the second trimester or
the beginning of the third trimester
what have you but this is not what this
is this is effectively a clump of cells
that we're talking about just several
weeks into a pregnancy and effectively
what you're doing by Banning these
abortion bills by trying to ban them is
delaying when a woman can likely get the
procedure done and this will give the
fetus more time to develop not to
mention it'll add cost it'll add stress
to the woman who's going through the
predicaments but Republicans they don't
care about that sort of stuff they see
pregnancy as a punishment for having sex
and they're not not interested in real
solutions they're not interested in
abortion pills or day after pills
they're not interested in other types of
contraception they're not interested in
sexual education they want to maximize
suffering on this issue increase
unwanted pregnancies keep people in this
cycle of poverty since of course
Parenthood is so incredibly expensive
and often people who are considering
abortions are doing so because they
can't afford to have a child or another
child obviously Republicans aren't in
support of social programs too that
would help the babies once they're
actually born so judge Matthew kasmarek
is digging up this matter from 20 years
ago
that's so incredibly legally dubious so
that he can play politics to enforce his
strict father morality View and it's
sickening to see how much we've
regressed in the year 2023 good on
District Judge Thomas O Rice issuing a
ruling in a separate case here and good
on the Biden Administration for trying
to challenge this hey get a load of this
one so North Dakota's Senate recently
passed a bill to increase the amount of
money that state employees can collect
for meals while they're traveling on the
job raised it from 35 to 45 dollars a
day and this is a benefit that lawmakers
of course will be able to enjoy as they
are state employees themselves so it's a
nice little perk that they've passed for
themselves and in a vacuum I really
wouldn't see a big issue over this the
bill is going to cost taxpayers a
million dollars over the next two years
and it's now waiting for the Governor's
signature to become law now forty five
dollars a day for food may sound like a
lot sure but you have to consider that
if you're traveling you're not really
going to be able to cook you're going to
be eating out exclusively or almost
exclusively so you think okay well
ten dollars for breakfast fifteen
dollars maybe for lunch twenty bucks for
dinner that adds up to 45 okay I think
this makes sense however here is the rub
less than two weeks ago the senate in
North Dakota rejected a separate bill
that would have provided six million
dollars over the next two years to give
free school lunches to all K-12 students
living at or below 200 percent of the
federal poverty level uh the bill failed
by a single vote with 13 Republicans
voting against it despite how they
backed this recent Bill about
reimbursement for state employees not
surprisingly the Democrats of course
backed the free school lunch bill the
rejected school lunch bill aims to
expand on an existing Federal program
that already provides meals to students
living below 130 percent of the poverty
level we're hearing some reactions from
North Dakota North Dakota lawmakers
about this including Senate minority
leader Kathy Hogan who's a Democrat she
criticized the senate for voting for
more free food for themselves while
rejecting the bill to provide food to
Hungry children however we're also
hearing from Republicans like assistant
Majority Leader Jerry Klein who claims
that he failed to see any correlation
between the two bills which is laughable
in my opinion because they both
literally have to do with paying for
meals for people uh one group of people
being State officials and the other
group of people being students and then
get a load of this one
state Senator Mike wilbaima cited
personal responsibility for why kids
shouldn't get free meals and blamed
negligent parents for the problem yeah
so lack of personal responsibility among
what kindergartners first graders second
graders I mean how does that make any
sense whatsoever real Galaxy brained
take there North Dakota has the second
highest child poverty rate in the U.S to
put this in context and over 30 percent
of its K-12 students qualify for free or
reduced price lunches so this state more
than almost every other state in the
Union is in need of a bill like this
because we know the importance of
providing lunches to kids it of course
ensures that they're going to have
access to adequate nutrition regardless
of their ability to pay it will increase
academic performance for kids because it
helps them focus on what they're
learning in class instead of focusing on
their stomach rumbling it helps with
their development as they're of course
still growing and it reduces stigma too
I remember when I was growing up in
school we had these yellow lunch tickets
if you were paying full price for the
lunch the full 3.50 or whatever it was
but there were also students who had the
reduced priced lunch tickets and those
were a different color maybe it was
orange I don't exactly remember and
there was also the free lunch tickets
which I think were maybe read
and so other students would see students
pay with the yellow tickets or the red
tickets or the green tickets and
everyone would kind of have an
assessment as to the financial situation
of the families of all these different
kids and you know if you're one of the
students who are paying with the
discount under free lunch tickets there
could easily be some stigma there right
there could be some self-esteem issues
that results from that some mental
health uh troubles that results from
that and so in my mind we should just do
away with this all together school lunch
is already incredibly subsidized and
it's something that we as a nation can
easily afford the pandemic era federal
aid made the school meals available for
free to all public school students that
ended uh on September 30th of last year
however it's unfortunate that we were
not able to keep this thing going and
make it permanent one of the longer
lasting results of the pandemic that
would have been nice to see to just set
this in stone and not go back on it but
unfortunately we are regressing on this
issue and leaving it up to the States
has not worked because seeing what
transpired here in North Dakota and it
really is too bad especially seeing the
contradiction that we're seeing with
them totally fine approving uh
increasing the costs that they're able
to spend when it comes to meals for
themselves but not when it comes to
students and the most disadvantaged
among us all right that's going to do it
for this segment of the David Pacman
show but stick around because we have
one more segment to go we'll be back
with much more right after this
commercial break
welcome back to the David Pacman show
I'm producer Pat Ford filling in for
David today he'll be back on Friday
right Wingers love to boycott Brands
nowadays typically they do so over the
silliest of reasons like they boycotted
Nike a few years back over the brand
supporting Colin Kaepernick they
boycotted Keurig because Keurig decided
to pull its advertising from a Fox news
program they boycotted Starbucks because
Starbucks decided to hire a bunch of
refugees in response to Donald Trump's
travel ban they boycotted the NFL and
Twitter and Coca-Cola and now Hershey's
lately the big one though has been Bud
Light because the company had the
audacity the temerity to make a
specialty can that celebrated
transgender influencer Dylan Mulvaney of
course Disney has also been a big one
because they've been butting heads with
Ron DeSantis over the don't say gay Bill
and other issues in Florida it's an
exhaustive list and it seems very
difficult for conservatives to be able
to keep track of all the different
companies they're supposed to be
boycotting but every time they hear
about a new one they tell themselves get
woke go broke and this is the phrase
they use to keep themselves going and to
make themselves feel as though their
boycott is actually working but the
truth is that many of these companies
aren't actually feeling the supposed
pain that these boycotts are supposed to
bring them and this was highlighted in a
recent piece from Rolling Stone it turns
out that many of these companies are
actually doing better than ever so for
example I mentioned Keurig since the
boycott happens they've acquired Dr
Pepper Snapple Group in a 18.7 billion
dollar deal and the company's annual
gross profits have swelled reaching 7.3
billion dollars in 2022 another example
is United Airlines United Airlines was
targeted by right-wingers because of all
things the airline decided to commit
itself to having half of its new pilot
trainees be either women
um and or people of color and since
making that decisions since the boycott
the company recently reported a fourth
quarter 2022 profit of 843 million
dollars which well beat Wall Street's
expectations Carhartt is another one I
didn't even know about this boycott
you'd think that Carhartt would be a
brand that conservatives would like
because it's associated with these
rugged blue color type jobs but they did
have a covid vaccine requirement for
employees and that sparked a boycott now
the company uh it's private so we don't
know the profits and too much about the
numbers but they did announce an
investment of 4.65 million dollars to
expand its Dearborn Michigan campus and
its plans uh it's planning on hiring 125
more workers at an average wage of 43
dollars and 22 cents per hour so that is
quite a good wage if I do say so myself
also Disney had a gross profit for 2022
which was 28 billion dollars a 27
increase from the previous year
we're hearing that Nike outperformed
expectations and had a fourth quarter of
2022 reaching over a billion dollars uh
the NFL had a dip in recent years with
the pandemic losing them some viewership
but now the league is unbelievably
prosperous and the individual teams are
increasing in value there's record
viewership among broadcast and streaming
Partners they're soaring in-person
attendance so what I'm getting at here
is that these right-wing boycotts aren't
actually working and these companies who
feel that they should send out an
inclusive message or have a vaccine
mandate or pay their workers a living
wage things that the left likes to
Champion they should feel as though they
have every that they have the green
light to do so because you know it's
working and the boycotts that they could
generate aren't actually going anywhere
part of this is the fact that
progressives and moderates outnumber
conservatives in the United States by a
wide margin but I think it's more so
that people really just don't have the
patience for these sorts of boycott and
they forget about the boycotts after not
that much time it's it's just hard to
keep track of all of it I mean listen to
all these different companies that I've
mentioned it's what you know at least 10
12 and people are eventually are just
going to get sick of it and lose track
and want to go back to buying the
products that they like and there's no
reason really why conservatives
shouldn't like Nike and Starbucks and
Carhartt and Keurig like everyone else
does
um so it's just a big commitment that
they're not even willing to follow
through with and that's why we're seeing
these boycotts really have no effects
and if they do want to boycott companies
for whatever reason they want to come up
with they can do that right they have
that right they can start these mass
media campaigns they're free to do so
this is the free market that they claim
to love so much but it's time to stop
pretending as though these boycotts are
having any sort of measurable effect and
it's certainly time to retire the phrase
get woke go broke because there doesn't
seem to be any Merit to it at all Donald
Trump wants to hire radical right-wing
activist Laura Loomer to his 2024
campaign staff and Loomer is such a
Nutty person that even radical repugnant
Marjorie Taylor green is trying to get
in the way of her hiring Trump has told
AIDs that he wants to hire Loomer this
is coming to us from a report from The
New York Times through four Anonymous
sources the time says that Donald Trump
met with Miss Loomer recently and
directed advisors to give her a role in
support of his candidacy Loomer was part
of the peanut gallery that was at
Trump's post arrest speech in Mar-A-Lago
last week of course the Trump campaign
staff is not happy with the idea of
hiring Loomer and that prompted her to
send out the message saying quote the
president knows I have always been a
trump loyalist and that I'm committed to
helping him win re-election in 2024 he
likes me very much and it's a shame that
he's surrounded by some people that run
to a publication that is notorious for
attacking him in order to try to cut me
at the knees instead of being loyal to
president Trump and respecting their
confidentiality agreements
she also said I know a lot of people
don't like me and that's their problem
not mine I have proven my loyalty to
president Trump countless times over and
even if other people try to malign me
and undermine president Trump's wishes I
will continue to be a ride or die Trump
supporter Trump deserves loyalty and he
deserves to have loyal people working
for him who do not leak to the press to
give you a picture as to who Laura
Loomer is she's mainly known for her far
right and anti-muslim activism in
November 2018 she was banned from
Twitter for violating the platform's
rules against hate speech she had
previously made controversial comments
about Muslims including calling for a
non-islamic uber those were hers words
non-islamic Uber and accusing Muslims of
supporting rape Uber and Lyft decided to
ban her from using the services over
these comments in 2017 she appeared on a
white supremacist podcast Loomer claims
that Jewish privilege exists in the
United States States and that Jews
control the media and politics this is
especially strange for her to say
because she herself is Jewish in 2018
Loomer showed up at the Twitter
headquarters in New York City I remember
when this one happened this was a wacky
story
and she handcuffed herself to the
building to protest her band from the
platform she also supports white
nationalism and has spread conspiracy
theories about covid-19 and the 2020
election but much of that is just par
for the course when it comes to
Republicans these days to give you an
idea as to how nuts Loomer is
representative Marjorie Taylor green who
you know again at least at one time
believed in Q Anon and Jewish space
lasers and thinks that Democrats or
pedophiles and wearing a mask is somehow
like the Holocaust she tweeted about
this idea to hire Laura Loomer saying
quote Laura Loomer is mentally unstable
and a documented liar she cannot be
trusted she spent months lying about me
and attacking me just because I
supported Kevin McCarthy for speaker and
after I had refused to endorse her last
election cycle that's the other thing uh
Laura Loomer did run for Congress at
least once she loves the alleged FBI
informant and weirdo Nick Fuentes she
tried to get hired on the yay campaign
after the infamous Mar-A-Lago dinner but
Kanye West refused to hire her so now
she's running to Trump never hire or do
business with a liar Liars are toxic and
poisonous to everything they touch I'll
make sure he knows okay so clearly
there's some personal animosity there
between Marjorie Taylor green and Laura
Loomer but even so when you're that
crazy when you're that far right that
conspiratorial that bigoted that even
Marjorie Taylor green is denouncing you
in this way and trying to get in the way
of you getting hired by the Trump
campaign that is when you know that you
are just completely off of the deep end
and Trump must be thinking hey I don't
really care about that stuff because I
agree with her on a lot of these issues
namely the uh 2020 election conspiracy
theories and the most important thing to
Donald Trump after all is loyalty Loomer
is loyal to Trump and arguably loyal
than other people are on his campaign
staff and so
that's enough for him it may be enough
to push him over the edge into actually
deciding to hire her however we've also
seen Donald Trump acquiesce to the
wishes of his campaign staff and his
Administration staff over the years and
so my sense is that maybe he'll be
talked out of it but just the fact that
he was meeting with her speaking to her
at Mar-A-Lago the fact that this idea
has been floated and it's getting this
attention and he's talking to insiders
about it that's how we know that this is
a complete unserious person as if we
didn't already know that already from
the years and years that we've been
witnessing Donald Trump but that's the
latest Laura Loomer may just may be able
to find herself a job in the Donald
Trump campaign all right that's going to
do it for today's episode of the David
Pacman show it's been a pleasure filling
in for David today I say I enjoy doing
it more and more every single time I do
it
uh it's not the end though for those of
you who are members if you go to
joinpakman.com and sign up for a
membership you'll be able to join me on
today's bonus show when we talk about a
few more stories today to everyone else
we'll see you next time
foreign